bonjour à toutes et à tous alors c'est
vrai que il ya eu des réponses qui m'ont
été avortée montagny tu m'as devancé
s'agissant de la relation avec les
collectivités ultramarines alors
messieurs sachez que la pêche illégale
est un sujet qui me tient à coeur en
guyane quand je vous entends je suis
contente pour vous parce que vous avez
les moyens vous disposez de moyens en
tout cas pour contrer ce phénomène alors
que nous on guyane nos pêcheurs
subissent des actes de violence même
s'il ya des relations de coopération
entre la guye la france la guyane le
brésil le surinam et le guyana je peux
vous dire que tous les jours les
parlementaires sont interpellés sur ce
sujet et j'aimerais bien d'ailleurs que
le contre-amiral et le général de
brigade puissent pouvoir nous faire
parvenir la liste des moyens dont vous
disposez parce que nous avons 10 youn et
la ministre de la mer qui nous a parlé
de deux bâtiments de deux drones
mais ça ne résout toujours pas le
problème de la pêche illégale en guyane
et c'est un sujet franchement qui me
tient à coeur d'autant plus que les
pêcheurs illégaux maintenant pêche dans
les fleuves donc c'est encore pire
il pénètre ça veut dire dans l'intérieur
du pays donc je pense que les les facs
donc les forces armées de guyane ne
dispose certainement pas des mêmes
moyens que vous danger mais j'aimerais
bien avoir la liste pour pouvoir
comparer et pouvoir justement sollicités
le gouvernement est censé suivre sur la
pêche illégale et les problèmes en
guyane mois de façon très factuelle ça a
été dit pour la réunion on a cassé les
reins des gens qui venaient piller nos
eaux on a pris leur bateau on les a on
les a confisqué on les a saisis on les a
confisqué on a d'un certain de ses
bateaux on les a transformé en
patrouilleur de l'état français et donc
on a ruiné les gens qui venaient piller
nos eaux et sont partie pliée ailleurs
après ils peuvent revenir chez nous le
général cluzel par l'élu du canal du
mozambique ce que je veux dire c'est que
ce qu'on a pu faire aussi dans les
autres calédonie avec les blue gold que
je citais dans la présentation
l'étanchéité et qu'on assure pour la
polynésie
je ne connais pas le théâtre guyane et
je n'ai pas eu la chance d'y servir mes
jeux il ya une question de profondeur de
différentes c'est vrai que les espaçant
sont moindres l'état pouliot brésilienne
peuvent aller se réfugier dans leur zone
donc il ya peut-être des choses à faire
avec les brésiliens
mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il ya
quand même un savoir faire une maîtrise
dans le domaine de l'action de l'état en
mer qui a montré son efficacité et il ya
je suis assez confiant sur la capacité à
faire de même en guyane même si encore
une fois j'ai pas aujourd'hui des sceaux